this is dave klein reading for jordan
remay i'm sure my cat will come around
once she sees the full release and hears
the meows coming from the virtual stray
i'm sorry blue 12 studio i know i wasn't
supposed to bring in any outsiders for
the straight demo but i just figured
having my cat sitting in attendance
wouldn't harm anyone penny is shy and
doesn't really talk to strangers after
all turns out she's not huge on story
either she refused to pay attention to
the stream and walked off after a few
minutes i don't know what her problem
was because i think straight looks like
a wonderful time stray sees you play as
a lost cat who has fallen into a
mysterious cyberpunk inspired city
hurt and separated from his friends and
family this stray seeks a means of
returning to the world above on his
journey destroy will encounter
human-like robot citizens that he can
interact with eventually gaining a means
of understanding and communicating with
them when he acquires a robot companion
that can translate for him you can
absolutely get distracted by just doing
cat things too stray includes plenty of
avenues for you to be an absolutely
adorable menace that terrorizes the
populace by knocking over objects
jumping on the tables or meowing at a
closed door until you're allowed entry
the main feature of stray is that you
play as a cat this comes with a few
perks producer swan martin rajay said
during the preview for instance we have
a button that you can press to meow the
good thing is that you can press this
button at any moment in the game
including during some cinematics so you
can really be as annoying as you want to
be
seeing these mechanics in action was the
point when penny stopped watching the
stream so it's possible she took offense
at the perceived slander which i can
confirm is not slander i love her but
she can be a menace
i just thought it all looked funny when
you're not scratching up rugs or
knocking over cans of paint stray sees
you exploring the city your main means
of navigation is the ability to leap
between select surfaces i was a tad
disappointed that there doesn't seem to
actually be all that much to platforming
the straight automatically makes jumps
so all the challenge comes from figuring
out the path not actually taking it
being a cat obviously allows for lots of
interesting level design opportunities
martin rojay said so we moved away quite
early in the project from a normal
platforming challenge
martin roger added that in early
concepts astray players regularly missed
a lot of jumps which got in the way of
feeling like an acrobatic and graceful
feline so we came up with this
compromise where every jump will be
successful in the game but still a lot
of freedom and ability to move anywhere
you want to in the more open-ended hub
areas i appreciate that freedom but
stress seems to have rather linear
portions of the game too where the path
forward is practically spelled out for
you i don't know how many times sections
like that pop up in the game but i'm
hoping they are few and far between
because simply pressing the jump button
over and over and not having to worry
about anything else doesn't seem
terribly exciting
i do really like the look of the chase
sequences though where the stray has to
outrun pursuers by scampering through
the streets or sewers forcing you to
make split-second decisions on not only
where to jump but when i saw a segment
where the jump ahead was obvious but
doing so immediately would have
catapulted a stray right into those
chasing him so the stray had to first
lead them away before doubling back and
then making the jump segments such as
that seem like a whole lot of fun making
you feel cat-like by rewarding your
ability to think on your feet where a
successful end to an adrenaline-inducing
chase is decided by your skill not just
pushing the jump button it wasn't
immediately clear what the margin for
error is for segments like that though
and whether the punishment for making a
mistake will result in a frustrating
loss of progress
we'll have to wait and see on that
beyond that there isn't much else you
can do gameplay wise and stray it
doesn't look to be a super mechanic
heavy game or one intensely geared
toward action or survival we do not have
any survival mechanics in the game
martin rojay said we moved away from
this quite early in the project so
everything that is about drinking and
eating food is just cosmetic we really
wanted to have the fantasy of being a
cat being as smooth as possible and
there are other types of challenges in
the game ultimately the aspect of stray
that leaves me most intrigued is the
story it wants to tell the preview only
provided hints at what to expect teasing
the potential discovery of lore behind
the world there's this tangible sense of
mystery hanging over almost everything i
saw who are the human-like robots how
did this cyber noir city come to be in a
society where most sentient life seems
to be mechanical how is there a
biological creature like a cat is this a
future earth an alternate reality or
somewhere else entirely
these questions are what have me most
intrigued to play stray nothing about
the gameplay leaves me terribly excited
but the world building on display here
has me wanting to snoop around i hope
there are plenty of secrets in the story
to uncover and martin rojay seems to
imply that there will be at its core
straight is an adventure game it has
puzzles and quest elements as well as
action sequences but it's really about
the story we won't have to wait all that
much longer to try out stray ourselves
given that is very close to release
story is set to launch for ps5 ps4 and
pc on july 19. the playstation versions
of the game will be available day one on
playstation plus via the subscription
service's two highest paid tiers
[Music]